mediocrity is everywhere right now and
we're also trying to find an easy way
out and we're judging ourselves let's
say there's 10 people in this room and
we're all mediocre but I'm the
I'm the mediocre people I'm now think
I'm great I'm great we surround
ourselves around people that make us
feel great they tell us what we want to
hear the second we put ourselves amongst
the uncommon people we don't like that
feeling that challenging at 3 30 in the
morning hey push yourself we're going
for a run we don't like that challenge
we like that person who says hey you
know what man I don't feel good today
man and they say oh it's okay brother
take a day off maybe get a pizza watch
the game we love that feeling why
because you understand man we're good
bro we don't want that like this hey man
no bro get your come on man stop being a
punk we don't want that in our lives we
don't want that person who's constantly
challenging our weaknesses we want that
process constantly you know making us
feel nice and good and secure nurse
that's the mediocrity of life we want to
be the best amongst the average people
hey seven Carmichael and I make these
videos because running the business is
hard and waking up every day and getting
to work when you're all by yourself is
hard and the thing that saved me that
continues to inspire me motivate me give
me hope inspiration ideas is looking at
the stories of people who've done a lot
more than me and I learned strategies I
get motivation and it gets me to believe
in myself to go off and attack the day
and so I hope this video inspires you to
do the same as well so today let's learn
how to stop being broke enjoy
people wonder how do you stay hungry all
the time
because after I accomplished something I
don't sit back like a lot of guys should
graduate budge graduate this graduate
that they get comfortable they wonder
why I'm getting weak man I don't know I
lost my Edge what's going on because
once you hit the top of the mountain
guess what happened
I'm good
I'm good so you wonder why you're
falling down now because once you're top
of the mountain you gotta build up
another one that's mediocrity there's a
lot of people in mediocrity who have a
nice resume
but they're one-timers man they hit they
hit a one-time deal they busted it open
got a lot of money but they're good
you're a mediocre now man what are you
doing today tomorrow the next day that's
why I'm listening to theorists I don't
listen all that [__] I listened to
who's like this man
what's wrong man I'm tired dude why are
you tired because tomorrow I gotta do
the fish again man whatever this [__] is
that made me nauseous and sick to my
stomach it made me hurt
there's no ending
and that's the person I listen to that's
the person who's gained knowledge you
gain knowledge through suffering
and on the other end the suffering is a
world that very few very few have ever
seen it's a beautiful world because
that's where you find yourself
you don't find yourself in over here you
find yourself on the other end like the
100 mile race I was on I ran it for 24
hours I found myself
on the other end of that race that 19
hours I found wow there's a whole nother
World out here that never even saw the
world's in your mind
and that's when all that mediocrity is
about mediocrity is contagious rule
number two is put in the work with Alex
hermosi hard work will not make you rich
I get driven nuts by the amount of gurus
and influencers and whatever who want to
brag and say no one can outwork me I'm
the best in the world so many people
outwork me I still make more money than
them there has to be something else one
of the things that grinds my gears about
a lot of the people that I see on
Instagram that you probably see too is
this whole like no one can outwork me
Mantra first off it's objectively false
because many people a outwork you today
be outworkived in the past see you
haven't met everyone indeed it doesn't
[__] matter anyways it's the same
thing when someone's like I'm the best
and you have to say you're the best
because if you don't think you're the
best it shows that you're not confident
to me I don't take that at all if
someone's like I'm the best then why
aren't you on billboards that's what the
best would look like absolutely you need
to do the work you need to put volume in
it's the only way you get better but if
you start claiming that you are the best
you cannot be outworked you are making
statements that you know are not true
why are we bragging about work because
work has very little to do with the
highest levels of the game Warren
Buffett talks about if he makes two good
decisions a year he's had a good year
and so how is it that one of the best
investors one of the best business
people in terms of measuring it by money
which is how you measure business talks
about how he does basically nothing
reads five or six hours a day eats
McDonald's and makes a couple good
decisions a year how is it that that guy
is making so much more money than the
people who are bragging about the fact
that they work so hard everyone only has
the same hours of the day anybody who
only sleeps eight hours or only sleeps
seven hours and works the remaining of
hours of the day all of them would be
tied for hardest working so what creates
output you have volume of activity and
then you have the leverage of the
activity that you're doing that's what
creates the total output in order to do
anything you must do something there has
to be some level of energy that gets
input into the system our activity in
terms of number of activities is a very
newbie measure of success in the
beginning Warren Buffett doesn't say
I sent a thousand emails today he
doesn't talk like that he's playing a
different game Jeff Bezos didn't like
woke up at 4am today now mind you I'm
saying this is somebody who likes waking
up early we can't be as superstitious
about what matters waking up early
doesn't matter going to bed late doesn't
matter not sleeping a lot doesn't matter
the few things that matter are the
inputs that go into the system that have
the most leverage to create the most
output now if you're a newbie and you
can't get your ass off the couch and by
all means figure out how to actually get
your ass off the couch and do stuff but
then there's only so many hours and so
boom and then very quickly you hit your
capacity of work great you've maximized
that now what the leverage that we have
on that activity is going to dictate how
much we get out of it and if we do a low
leverage activity many many many times
we might get more than a high leverage
activity that gets done once a CEO who's
going to work with acquisition.com Works
virtually every hour of every day when
they come in almost everybody does
sometimes they ask they're like am I
going to be working more or like it's
impossible for you to work more but you
are going to be changing what you work
on because that's the only lever we have
there's only 24 hours so we're going to
switch these nine out and we're going to
plop these in with higher leverage
activities and so the way that we do
that is we look at their calendars and
we look at their org chart this is how
you grow a business you look at what
they spend their time on and you see
which of these activities are low
Leverage is there anyone else in this
org chart that we can hand these
activities to and if a large percentage
of these activities are a certain type
of thing and they don't exist in their
chart then it's a role that we need to
hire the point of why I hate the concept
of no one cannot work me is that there
are many ways to win the game if you
were to think about an amazing goal as a
dragon to be slain if you are familiar
with video games in any way when you
create like a war party you have a group
of people that are going to go go on a
quest you don't just have 10 paladins or
guys who just have Shields and swords so
you've got a Healer a mage that's really
good at damage but can't take a lot of
damage then you've got a paladin who
can't hit as hard but he can take a lot
of shots you find people who have
complementary skills if you're playing
football you don't have 10 running backs
the entrepreneur really should be the
coach of the team it's about organizing
the pieces and how the well they play
together that ultimately determines how
good the team is like how many times
have you seen the team the All-Star that
has the poor Supporting Cast get beat by
the overall better team it happens all
the time a lot of entrepreneurs as I see
them are trying to play the game like
they're the star player and they want to
score all the points but they lose to
Apple because Apple's got a team we
celebrate a specific action like work
when it's really just saying oh look
there's a paladin who can take a lot of
hits cool that's not the only thing
that's required to win I think what is
more valuable is to know what are each
of the roles that exists within the
business a b is there one of these that
you map to based on your characteristics
and skill sets and then see what is my
eventual Evolution through
entrepreneurship we'll start at the
beginning which is what are the players
on the field so if you think about it by
function you've got somebody who has to
promote who's got to be a good marketer
they have to understand how to make
things known across different platforms
telling stories building a brand
providing value to an audience that's
what marketing is sales is being able to
convert that raw attention into a sale
direct response ads sales Pages video
your sales letters Etc which is pretty
much anything that's physical products
or software based that's low ticket or
it's higher ticket people-to-people
hand-to-hand combat who know how to in
the beginning sell and then later train
how to sell and then later later lead
people who train how to sell these are
not necessarily the same people I've met
really brilliant marketers who suck at
sales I'm a really good sales people
sucking marketing then you've got
somebody who understands product how do
we make something beautiful the guy who
started Shopify he's not CEO of Shopify
he's had a product he's a mage he knows
how to cast spells and you've got the
experienced people who are managing
everything outside of the actual product
itself how do customers engage with us
how it can provide more value how to
give an amazing experience how do we
make sure they're hitting these miles
though this person who knows customers
experience and customer success is not
the same person who understands product
and ux and design that's a different
game which is different the guy who
knows how to close this different guy
that knows how to promote the bigger the
Enterprise gets the more specialized the
skill becomes and the deeper The Well of
experience that people need to be they
have to be more specialized when people
are like I can't be outworked you're
bragging about the wrong thing it should
be like I can't be out recruited I can't
be outmanaged no one can build a culture
like me that's super high leverage
across the organization no one can lead
like me but no one can outwork me
it's just an irrelevant activity metric
I love working I work all the time but I
would never claim that no one works
harder than me I tend to have very good
leverage with the activities that I do I
spend tons of time writing a book in
that book prints and sells copies
forever it's a different way to play the
game and so level two of this which
player you are in the Middle Run of this
you end up segregating yourself to a
portion of the business that you're an
expert at or that you're best at CMO or
chief sales officer Chief product
officer it's not about one player being
the champion here it's about how the
team works together which then gets to
the third level of this is just about
being the coach think about the best
coaches do they're literally trying to
head hunt the best players and they're
trying to recruit the best people from
college look at what Google does think
about their recruiting efforts they have
huge influxes dedicated to getting the
best and smartest people out of college
and they have another ring for the best
and smartest people come out of business
school and then another one is their
very high level recruiting at the top of
the executive level the parallels
between sports and business they are
almost the same in that way now mind you
you can only have you know 10 or 11
people on the field you might have ten
thousand but if each of those players
represents a a function or Department of
the business it makes more sense when we
move up the levels of Entrepreneurship
we need to make sure that we're playing
the right game and that we're using the
right metric to measure our success
final level of this is being the coach
is recruiting the top level Executives
and creating a farm system underneath to
feed into the company that you have so
you can have a sustained competitive
advantage and create a dynasty for the
team so you can create the best winning
team every year and have the soft skills
of creating culture of high performance
so that you get the most out of every
individual player and the difference
between amazing coaching and mediocre or
poor coaching is what would players do
if they had no coach or leader and then
what would they do if they had the best
coach and best leader the Delta between
those two is the value of the coach the
value of the CEO the CEO needs to have
the highest return on time out of anyone
in the organization because they need to
always be solving the next problem as
long as when they replace their time the
activities they do with the new stuff
builds the business even more then that
trade will always work and if Co can
come in and turn a business around even
behemoths around in two three years
based on the standard that they set and
the values that they stand for that
Delta across the entire organization is
your greatest leverage rule number three
is lean into positivity with Gary
vaynerchuk lean in dramatically more to
things that are positive your
grandfather
podcasts
upworthy.com lean into positivity then
they should be on the awareness Eyes
Wide Open on is this delusional and
lacks practicality like you know if I
just dream it it will happen no
lean in cut out literally when this
podcast is over step back audit your
entire life
from the people you spend time with your
family your friends look at every person
you follow are they triggering your
insecurities for their own self-interest
are they trying to put love into it so
that you go on and do your thing watch
look for it but whatever you do
back to like working out like you know
protein and you know when I when you
know when Mike vacancy is like all right
you did a left like protein I'm like
really okay and like during cooking I'm
like wait a minute I'm starting to
finally get some muscles oh because I
was doing protein as [__] after lifts
and not after not lifts I was doing it
right here's something right for
everyone cut out one hour of negativity
add one hour of positivity
if you're listening right now and you're
like uh social's such a drag it's
because you're in a drag mindset and the
Algos and the people you follow are
following you you know what my social
looks like sunshine
I'm being dead serious you know my Algos
look like
sunshine in the world of the momentum of
Darkness right now sunshine you know why
I choose to fight
for positivity but I refuse to not be
grounded in practicality which is why
I've always thrown curveballs love
everybody it's all awesome Faith Place
trophies what Gary what what eighth
place trophies lead to entitlement and
fear of losing and if some kids so like
it's kind of that juxtaposition
practical positivity is something
everyone needs to add more also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there room number four is start taking
action with Mel Robbins close your eyes
and think about the next year of your
life
what do you want the next year of your
life to look like
Begin by making a wish
that's how I began two years ago
yep my business was upside down kids
were in shambles my husband was
struggling with depression and I was
struggling with everything
I had to create a break from that moment
of pain
and allow myself to see something
different at the time
I had no idea what the new chapter of my
life would be or could be here's what I
did know I want to stay in this one and
that's all you need to know
all you need to know is you don't want
to stay in the place that you're in
right now
that right there is a wish for something
better if you know what you don't want
it's very easy to change as soon as you
start removing or letting go of things
that aren't working you'll see all new
possibilities no matter how you feel
start taking the actions that align with
what you want in your life
stop making the mistake of waiting to
feel happy or motivated before you take
action the secret it's taking action
first because if you can get moving you
can keep moving and research shows that
just a little boost in your mood impacts
your productivity for the rest of the
day it impacts your focus it gives you a
little uptick in energy taking actions
that align with the bigger vision and
the future you it Taps into this huge
body of research called behavioral
activation therapy now you're going to
learn a tremendous amount about this
therapy modality in future episodes of
the Mel Robbins podcast but here's how
I'd summarize it for you act like the
person you want to become in the future
no matter how you feel in the present
moment look I know it sounds simple act
like the future you but this is grounded
in decades of research and it works this
is how I've made every single change in
my life once I figure out what I want to
do or the kind of person I want to
become I figure out someone else in the
world that's doing it and I just reverse
engineer it and that's how you create a
brick path that leads from where you are
right now to where that wish of yours
wants to take you and every morning wake
up take one action in the lines with
what you want or the person that you
want to become and you can consider that
action it represents one brick
and if you keep doing that day by day
Brick by Brick action by action you're
going to look up a year from now and
you'll realize oh my God I just paved a
brick path leading to my dreams rule
number five is improve yourself with
Grant Cardone you guys are just getting
started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there okay
probably in another city another town I
grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana no
money raised by a single mother I was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that I had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that I
improved myself and I could start
depending upon me I had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that I started doing was beating the Sun
up every morning
I'm gonna beat that son up every morning
so that I had the discipline and the
control of over my life
so I knew hey before that thing pops I'm
gonna pop I'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where I was was beat that
son up no matter where I am I'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing I had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when I
was younger between 15 and 25 I was
doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends I have the same
weekends or for the week
I was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people making poor choices
at 25 years old I cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life that weren't committed to the
same things that I was
I wanted to build something in my life I
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing I had to do was
become someone I could depend on so put
some things together three or four
things you can do every day to start the
day kick start your day get going in
your day to give you a sense of respect
for yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that scent up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said
said I was going to do that I woke up
when I said I would wake up and I start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today maybe today when I go into this
meeting that I'm dressed for maybe
they'll believe in me as much as I
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money
beat the Sun up rule number six is
change your mindset with Tom bilyu if
you want to be successful mindset is
everything the reason that mindset is so
important is at the end of the day only
execution matters so if you have big
dreams if you have goals something that
you're trying to accomplish in your life
you're going to have to execute against
that so why do I say that mindset is so
important in that scenario the reason is
that ultimately to achieve the things
you want to achieve I can promise you
when you start out you're not good
enough yet to achieve that and or you
don't have the right plan and so the way
to refine the plan to actually do the
thing that you want to accomplish you're
going to have to run through what I call
the physics of progress the physics of
progress are very simple they require
you to have a hypothesis which is simply
your best guess this is what I think I
have to do to achieve my goals then
you're going to turn that into something
you can do you're going to do that thing
it's going to fail to some degree that's
just the way it works but failure is the
most information Rich data stream on
planet Earth but to accurately assess
the data and figure out what it's
telling you about why you failed to some
extent or why it was more
inefficient than it needs to be
you have to be willing to stare nakedly
at your own inadequacies take
responsibility for the outcome not make
it somebody else's fault or the
economy's fault or whatever any external
Force if you're making it an external
problem you're never going to be able to
learn the lesson you need to learn in
order to improve your behavior so that
you can then execute better and make
more progress that really is it that's
the physics of progress hypothesis
turn it into something actionable run
that action learn from the partial
failure get a little bit smarter
come up with a new hypothesis that is
more informed turn it into something
actionable run that it will fail again
to some degree figure out why by
lowering your defenses having a growth
mindset making sure that you are able to
take on the responsibility now why is
that a mindset question why can't you
just run that equation if it really is
that simple the answer is you have in
your brain something called the
psychological immune system this is
something given to you by millions of
years of evolution we should all be
extremely grateful for it and the
psychological immune system's job is to
make sure that you don't commit suicide
it is designed to make you feel better
about things it's the reason why you can
mess up make a mistake and you can
soothe yourself now the problem is that
the goal of the psychological immune
system is not for you to achieve your
goals it's simply to make sure that you
feel good enough about yourself that you
can keep moving through life
now the reason that that becomes wildly
problematic and is one of the most
important things you have to address in
your mindset if you're going to be
successful is because the number one
tool that your psychological immune
system works to soothe your ego is to
make everything somebody else's fault it
is the fault of the government it is the
fault of rich people it is the fault of
not being born the right color not being
born the right sex so on and so forth it
is making something the external problem
now here's the really bad news your
psychological immune system is going to
grab for a very valid excuse those
things that I listed may all be true
they may really all be holding you back
the problem is you want to know what the
right mindset for success is and if you
want to be successful you are going to
have to overcome a endless parade of
problems and to overcome the endless
parade of problems you have to have a
way to take responsibility
for what you can do differently to
overcome those problems instead of being
annoyed instead of shutting down instead
of just pointing the finger you want to
adapt your behavior and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is learn to adapt
with Simon signic so every time there's
been new technology uh we have adapted
and changed of course I remember this is
going to date me now but I used to have
like a mind like a steel trap for phone
numbers I knew everybody's phone numbers
I knew 10 50 100 phone numbers like
family friends I just knew all phone
numbers and then for my birthday I got a
Casio digital diary with 2K of memory
and I was able to put all my phone
numbers in there now I I know my phone
number and I know my sister's phone
number and that's it I don't even know
my best friend's phone number I just
type in their names on my phone my mind
literally doesn't work that way anymore
because the technology is did the work
for me and my brain said fine screw you
you got the technology you don't need me
so yes of course there are going to be
adaptations you know the Iliad for
example was a was a a a book that we
read in high school or college that's
this big that was handed down by
storytelling over Generations until we
figured out the printing press and now
we can't remember stories that long we
just can't do it so will our minds
adjust thanks to Ai and chat GPT of
course for better and For Worse yes we
will adapt
stop trying to do this alone
if you've got a big idea inside you you
can't do this alone you need people
around you to help you to encourage you
to support you to cover your weaknesses
to help you actually go off and
accomplish that big dream of yours this
is one of the biggest things that I
think holds people back holds
entrepreneurs back
is you're probably decently good at the
thing that you want to do
you know you've had some experience or
you've gone and learned and figured it
out and you still to get better as you
keep practicing keep going and doing
more and maybe at some point you even
did try to hire somebody maybe at some
point you did try to bring somebody on
and it didn't work out
didn't work out
and here's where everybody makes the
mistake you Retreat and go back to say
you know what it was just a lot faster
when I did it myself does that happen
has that happened to you ever been there
you hired somebody you thought I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna hire somebody you do
it it doesn't work out
and then you go back to say I'm just
going to do this all myself no no no no
no no no that is not the answer
that is not the answer that's like if
you go on one date and it doesn't work
out now you're never going to go on
another date again you're never gonna be
married
right that doesn't make sense
that doesn't make sense you're living in
fear as opposed to actually trying to
build the thing that you're capable of
building
here's what happens
when you first hire somebody you know
what you're doing
right
it's like when you first did anything
you don't know what you're doing
so why do you expect to be great at
picking the right person and then
treating them well then managing them
well you don't know what you're doing
there's a guy in my movement makers who
who joined my Discord as well
and he was talking about how he had
hired his second video editor and it
didn't work out
and he had to let the person go so he's
hired two video editors both of them
couldn't get his style
and he had to let them go and he's going
back to editing everything himself now
as a short-term solution great like
stuff has to get up videos have to be
edited get them out
but don't stop searching
just because you had two failed hires
right like if you tomorrow are editing
videos awesome but if you next year are
still editing your videos not awesome
nope not awesome not anymore right this
is how we start to raise our standards
and so the first two people that you
hired weren't good fits great keep
searching keep looking
your perfect fit is out there and as you
go through some people and go through
the process you'll get better at
actually finding the right person
you know you'll get better at it don't
judge yourself that say well I suck at
this I can't hire I'm never going to
find the person it's just faster to do
it myself right there's that old
expression you can go fast by yourself
but you go far with the team
you have to build a team so let's talk
about how to do it okay let's stop let's
talk about steps practical steps
building the team creating the culture
someone who now has 37 people on the
team I'm not I'm not Jeff Bezos with uh
I don't know how many thousands of
people are on this team but 37 on our
team right now how do you how do you go
from starting up to that step number one
is figure out what is the most important
skill
that you need that has to get done in
the business that you suck at
okay and you don't want to get better at
what do you suck at that has to get done
in the business not something that you
know maybe it's a nice to have but like
it has to get done in the business you
suck at it and not just you suck at it
right now you just you never want to get
better at it you're just not interested
in it some people love this thing and
you hate it and you never want to get
better at it what is that thing
that's the first person you need to
bring on into your business it could be
part-time it it I it definitely should
not be a full-time person
here's why
one you don't know how to hire yet
two it's going to take you too long to
be able to save up the money to hire
somebody full-time and three you're not
used to managing people
so you want a part-time person when I
first started I had interns I had
interns from high school who were
helping me do a lot of the things that I
need to get done and it was part of
their school credit Nina is back
I did foreign language interns so people
came to Toronto as part of their
education
being from a different country learning
English and getting job experience
and find people I've had people
volunteer to join I've had people work
one hour a day to join right just like
you need to start getting some people
involved because
it makes you feel like you're not alone
doing this which is a big deal and it
also starts building some traction you
know starts finally getting some of the
things off your plate that you wish
didn't exist anymore and suddenly now
they don't because someone else is
taking care of it right step number two
is you have to start
asking for help this is a big problem
for a lot of entrepreneurs you're afraid
to ask for help at the startup phase
especially
well so what if they steal my idea it's
one of the most common questions we ever
felt that what if what if I tell
somebody my idea and they steal it they
go with it
well
it's possible
it's possible very low possibility most
people are are running their own
business the amount of people have come
to me and say Evan uh I'd love your help
on this but but I need you to sign this
NDA non-disclosure agreement it's like I
don't care about your idea
I have my own business to run I've got
my own channels my own team my own
things to worry about I'm not gonna they
think the top priority is you have some
great idea that I'm going to then take
and run with that that's now my new
business plan no and now you missed the
chance to actually get some feedback and
help
so you have to share your ID the idea
alone is not enough it's the execution
it really matters
so it's not just the idea that you've
got it's can you be the one to go off
and create it to make it to to birth it
to turn it into reality and speed
matters
have you ever seen anybody with your
idea right air quotes your idea
go off and win while you were still
sitting on the sidelines
right is that seen it happen so many
times have so many people message me
about it it's like I had this idea three
years ago and I didn't do it and now
here's this person off making millions
off of it well what's the difference
chances are they had less heart than you
less less
of a drive to do good less caring than
you so why are they winning well because
they started and they asked for help
and you were trying to do it all by
yourself
so you have to share your idea you have
to recruit people on board you have to
ask for help because those people can
make the difference between you actually
following through on your goals
I'm in step three is you have to Mentor
the people on your team you have to care
about them as humans the next big
mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make when
they're when they're hiring is okay this
person's gonna come on they're going to
take all the stuff off my plate so I can
focus on being the CEO and then
everything's gonna be great
and that's a nice Theory
um you know that that kind of happens
but what you want to think about is
this is a human working with you
you know this is a human who's got goals
and their own Ambitions and their own
dreams and your job should be to help
them grow as a human that they should be
better
as a person by spending time with you by
being around you
and by being in your company
most people treat people like robots
they treat them like monkeys okay get
this done get that done perfect gun you
know you made you made my life easier
awesome that's what you're hired to do
go do your job
where where
people make the mistake of is one not
giving enough training at the beginning
like did you actually set somebody up
for success and the two just not caring
about them enough as a human
I'm actually starting to find it harder
as I grow it was a lot easier when I had
one to five people on the team but at 37
I don't know what everybody's up to I
don't remember everybody's projects I'm
not in as much of the day-to-day of what
they're doing I find it hard to balance
everybody's
goals and just stay on top of of their
life and I don't know what it's going to
look like when we're at 50 people or 75
people or 100 people I don't know what
that process looks like I'm figuring out
you know what I gotta ask for help as I
grow
but two of the things that I've done
that have worked out pretty well
the first is
I dedicate Mondays to team days
so I have an entire day
of the week that's dedicated to team
and so
I'm spending that day on Zoom calls or
in person meeting with Team asking them
what's going on helping them with their
projects and just spending time with
them and so people know that on Mondays
when they save all their stuff and talk
to me about it
scheduling in time for Team matters so I
have different things for different days
of the week today's a Tuesday because
I'm recording so recording is Tuesday
but yesterday was Monday and and I was
spending the whole time basically on
Zoom calls with team
the second thing that I'll do is a is a
quarterly check-in with people and we
don't even talk about the business
you should do it on a Sunday so it's not
a work day it's a Sunday morning coffee
every Sunday I'm spending with someone
on my team
so Sunday morning I grab my coffee they
grab whatever drink they want and we do
a session together and we will touch on
business we'll touch on what they're
doing but not operationally focused not
hey you didn't get this thing done or
hey how are we doing on this project
it's more like where do you want to go
with your life
what do you curious about what are you
loving about the work that you're doing
here how can I help you get to the next
step what else are you curious about
what are your other goals just just a
life conversation
and you'd be surprised that
what comes out
and most people all they all they really
need is just somebody to listen to them
and care
and sometimes action happens immediately
after sometimes it happens you know the
next month or the next quarter but when
you know the hopes the goals the dreams
the Ambitions of the people on your team
the people around you it allows you to
be a much better and much more effective
leader
so we took you to this the process of
startup zero you know Team all the way
to now how do you manage you know your
first 37 at least people in your company
but underpinning all of this is
the understanding that you can't do this
alone you wanted to be a professional
baseball player is that right yeah but
then you got an injury I did similar to
me so you never made it to the big
league so did you play minor league I
did yeah and I played division one
college baseball too yeah I like every
guy like you and I talked about this
last time it's always our injuries that
ended our careers I probably it probably
put me into a premature place where I
was going anyways you aren't going to be
in The Bigs for I wasn't I played enough
baseball with guys who ended up in the
big leagues to know my limitations yeah
so like anything in life things happen
for you not to you that injury happened
for me it certainly didn't seem like it
at the time but it got me out of that
and into something like what we're
talking about now that completely
changed my life so yeah but yeah I want
to be an athlete for sure all my life
all your life that was my mask and then
when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and I were
just talking before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were there rare changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever your dream is
when the first one ends it doesn't
happen whether that be a relationship it
could be your marriage it ends it was a
dream right or a business venture or a
sport I went into a pretty good
depression and uh and how old were you
at the time 21 22 and I ended up you
know it's because people always see the
after like the house or whatever houses
or whatever the material things are but
I ended up bad man I ended up to press I
ended up moving back at home with my
parents I was living in the city I
remember I was living in this sleeping
in the same bed I grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters like
going back in time like six years on
back where I was totally unemployed and
uh couldn't find work didn't have the
motivation to get up and find a job just
sort of eating out of their fridge and
laying around all day so that's where I
was many many years ago after baseball
when you realize things in your life
happen for you truly especially in
hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any
disaster tragedy most people look back
five ten years later that happened for
me that was actually a good thing and so
so I was unemployed I couldn't find a
job and my old man my dad was the best
dad role model he could ever have in
your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter
my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there I said I'm Ed
mylett I'm here for the job you're like
what job I'm like I don't know just my
dad told me to show up here yeah I need
to ask for Tim they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is that's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh damn yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like a literally McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yeah all boys
it's in San Dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because I I'd
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask I wanted to compete I wanted to win
I wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
while I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like man love me believe in
me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden
I wasn't a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me it was about these 10
boys that ended up being 10 of them and
it just altered my life man and so after
that I ran into the financial business
that I ended up in but I would have
completely flunked out of that Financial
business had I not been with my boys for
those years and I was there for two
years two years yeah man like eight
hours a day type of thing or sometimes
more sometimes 16 18. I I think about
I'm not kidding you I think about my
boys and my experience there two of them
are still very close with me uh every
day there's a moment where I reflect on
that it altered me completely like what
I wanted to do I always wanted to be
famous and Rich and successful and now I
just wanted to serve yeah I wanted to
help the little did I find out I could
get rich and famous and all that other
stuff I thought I wanted through serving
people your personality literally ad is
made up of how you think how you act and
how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called the memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on with
extended periods of time so that the
event produces a chemical change and the
body needs to return back to homeostasis
or balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right wow so then what's
the significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power away wow to
that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though
it's been addicted to that emotion
because you're using that person to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred or
frustration and if that person died
you'd find another one so then here you
go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened or it's happening
to you so the moment you open your heart
and you feel gratitude well that emotion
then is telling the body that the
experience has already occurred and the
thought then can make it into the body
because it's consistent with the thought
so now you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right frames
when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right
meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by
that
when we start something new
I think sometimes we forget
that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that you know is the
reward neurochemical
and we feel good because we've taken on
this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our
brain whether it's starting to exercise
or eating better or committing to doing
something that's of benefit to us or
even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain
works is that patterns that have been
repeated over you know months and years
are the dominant patterns in our brain
and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to
completion on those patterns it's like
having a you know highway system that's
been built it's easy for the cars to go
faster on the highway system well the
same thing is true with our brain and
the neural networks and Pathways so the
pathways are the easiest for the
chemicals to travel across and release
the
neurochemicals you know that make us
feel good or make us feel fearful or
make us feel apprehensive or doubtful
Etc are the ones that are the easiest
for our brain to activate and follow
through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning
stopping something or starting something
requires a little bit more of the
brain's energy and the Brain wants to
conserve energy so what is our brain
naturally going to do and the answer is
it's going to resist why because it
wants to preserve the energy that may be
required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know
the the woods to try and kill you so
we're in this energy conservation
mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things
that are easy for us not things that
require energy right glucose
so why am I sharing this with you well
as you're you know on your journey of
brain training upgrading your Knowledge
and Skills taking actions probably
different actions that you were taking
to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of
um it requires you accessing higher
cortical functions and a higher level of
awareness especially pay close attention
especially
when you feel resistance now I came out
here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work
as I was doing you know some bench press
and flies for my chest one of the things
that dawned on me is most people do
things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a
cardiovascular perspective you have to
challenge yourself mix up your routines
you've got to go a little bit longer a
little bit harder
you know on the days that you want to
expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for
strength training or building muscle
there's certain techniques to use in
certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest
phase so let me explain what I'm talking
about I think you know where I'm going
with this
when I let's say do a bench press or fly
or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I
just can't do another rep that's the
point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance to point out I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is
how you expand your capacity resistance
happens
when you're at the edges of Your
Capacity now it could be mental edges
emotional edges physical edges Financial
edges and how does it show up it shows
up as stress
right stress so stress happens when your
current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current
capacity exceeds
the demand
your current capacity exceeds demand so
how do you increase demand I'm sorry how
do you increase capacity well you feel
the edges and go one more you feel the
tension and keep doing it you feel the
desire to quit but then you do as much
as you can and as you do as much as you
can you get mentally stronger physically
stronger emotionally stronger
so when I feel like let's say quitting I
just say just a little bit more when I
don't feel like it I say I know but just
do a little bit why because I want to
override my natural and your natural
propensity to want to quit to want to
stop it's natural
but I don't want to be natural I want to
be Supernatural I don't want to be
ordinary I want to be extraordinary and
that's that little extra does that make
sense so as you're training your brain
as you have videos to watch to upgrade
your Knowledge and Skills as you have
events to attend you know to to connect
to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or
feeling I don't feel like it I'm too
tired not today tomorrow that's the
language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that
your brain my brain everybody's brain
uses to keep you in your comfort zone
well guess what everything you want
financially in your relationship
health-wise is just outside your comfort
zone if you keep challenging and
expanding your mental emotional physical
spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start
fulfilling more of your potential than
standing on the edge of it hoping and
praying and wishing that you can have
greater better results first and
foremost we are going to have to figure
out what exactly has happened
so
is it that you don't have a dream or
passion because you haven't taken the
time to
Define that because let me be very clear
passion is not
an archaeological dig
it's an architectural build
so you don't turn in words look inside
yourself and find this glowing Ember of
passion and excitement
that's been sitting there since birth
despite that some people will tell you
that that's how this works but it is not
if Steve Jobs were born a thousand years
ago he would not have dreamed of making
the iPhone what ends up happening is you
decide
there is something that you decide means
enough to you that you're going to
invest in it and then over time that
investment turns that thing into a deep
and abiding passion as you get better
and you get feedback from the world that
they value this thing that you're
getting better at but it isn't just
lying dormant within you and this is
like the number one confusion that I
encounter with people is they think that
either they're broken and other people
were born with a passion and they were
not
or
they just think that
you know if I do enough introspection
I'm going to find something sitting
inside of me and finally my life will be
amazing
once you realize that in fact what
happens is when you look inside all
you're going to find are these Sparks of
Interest
and from that spark of Interest
through pursuing it as
a process of gaining mastery
it will become a passion when you're
able to use that skill set that you
gained in the pursuit of Mastery to
serve not only yourself but other people
okay so doing that now you're in this
passion Loop of you worked really hard
you gained this set of skills allows you
to serve other people they give you
feedback oh my God thank you this is so
amazing I'm grateful for what you've
done build created given me whatever the
case may be and that feels good which
makes you want to go get better and
that's the passion Loop
now as you're doing that
you're able to really be energized by
the things you're doing
but it doesn't start by looking Inward
and finding something it starts by
realizing that you have to Fan those
flames of that spark of interest to turn
it into the Raging Inferno that you want
to feel of that passion but that comes
from that Loop
okay so that's the first thing to assess
now if you already have or had a passion
but this job has somehow beaten it out
of you that's a very different story and
so if that's what's going on we need to
figure out what is it in the structure
of that that is robbing you of that
what's going on exactly that's making
this overwhelming or stressful or not
fun is it politics in the office is it
just the work environment is too fast
paced is it that you're not being honest
with yourself about you know going back
to this idea 50 of you is hardwired 50
of you is malleable if the hardwired
part is out of step with the life that
you're trying to lead there can be a lot
of frustration there so having the
self-awareness to understand did you put
yourself in the wrong position are you
trying to be Steve Jobs when you should
be Steve Wozniak that's a really
imperative thing to look at now I find
that a lot of times uh companies have
their own issues whenever you get a
large group of people together there are
going to be weird things that have to be
navigated but at the end of the day
while you can can't control everything
that everybody does you can always
control how you react and so you can
reorient yourself within a company to
figure out one if there's a
a path back to finding that Joy but that
comes from breaking down what exactly
happened that made you stop feeling the
joy and two are you able to perform at a
high enough level that you're able to
create the space for you to get back on
track because if you're going to go in
and try to move things around and make
some changes within the company or
within your role or within how things
work you're gonna need to be performing
at a very high level to have the
credibility to make that ask and this is
where it gets difficult nobody wants to
hear this I get it everybody wants to
point fingers and say this is just a
toxic company but in reality if it's
that bad leave do not waste time start
find another job first I'm not just
saying quit find another job but get out
of there don't act like you're actually
in prison you are not actually in prison
and yes I understand that you have
obligations and you may be a single
parent with kids and huge responsibility
I completely understand and I have the
most empathy for that in the world but I
want you to understand
you are only as trapped as you allow
yourself to be if you have a useful
skill set you will be able to find
another job and now is the time to go
looking for that while you're still
getting paid
now if you don't have skill set that's
marketable that's where we have to start
and so building up the skill set
so that we can be marketable somewhere
else that's going to give us the ability
to perform where we are or leave if it's
too toxic but assuming that we're going
to stay now we need that skill set to
perform at a very high level to create
the credibility to make the ask and go
to your boss or whomever is creating or
maybe not even creating the problem but
who has the ability to help you create
the solution now you go and say I'm
performing at a high level yes yes oh my
God you're amazing okay cool here are
the things that I would need to change
so often people's first instinct is just
peace out and they don't realize that
there are many things that they could
have done
to restructure the role to create more
space for themselves in order to stay
but what people end up letting happen is
they let themselves burn out and then
they want to leave and go somewhere else
not realizing that they will have the
same problem at the next job and instead
of doing the work themselves solving the
internal problem of how we ended up here
whether it's lack of skill set not
setting boundaries whatever the case may
be but keeping that ownership keeping
that responsibility recognizing that if
you make different choices you get
different outcomes so that you can go
ahead and change things there now again
if you want to leave leave by all means
take your skill set and go elsewhere but
make sure that you're not doing what I
was doing in my early 20s when I was
about to move to New York because I was
unhappy in LA and I thought the LA was a
problem in reality it was my mindset
once I changed my mindset suddenly I was
amazing
because it wasn't about la
it was about me and I thought ah like
something's got to change and so I just
wanted to go as far away as I could but
it wouldn't have solved the problem I
would have gotten to New York only to
have the same issue again and again and
again
I had to address my mindset and once I
did that then everything changed
so be very careful be very thoughtful
about
how you approach unwinding this problem
if you're always blaming other people
you're not going to get where you want
to go because you're not looking for the
things that you can do differently your
letting your psychological immune system
take over make it other people's
problems and then you're not able to
change
and once you realize that your life is
an exact reflection of your choices
now it's not so you feel bad it's so
that you remember if you make different
choices you get different outcomes and
so now you can make these changes or
gain more skills or whatever it is
that's needed to get the life that you
want now no matter where you go you will
feel completely comfortable that you can
shape things to your liking but you have
to know how the game works
you have to know that building skill set
is the key you have to know that
communicating with your boss what's
working what's not working and to have
earned the credibility to make the ask
do all that you'll have no problem when
it comes to an affirmation affirmations
can be powerful uh
and for some people they're not
and a lot of people say well you know if
the the affirmation is so powerful how
come I'm not experiencing the effect the
what scientists tell us is the average
human
speaks to themselves consciously or
unconsciously we have thoughts spinning
around in our brain about 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day some of those thoughts
are the words to the songs and they are
the affirmations
uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg tells
us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um
in his work that that a single word a
single word has the power to to change
the genes that creates stress or relieve
stress in our lives he's telling us that
that something within us has the ability
to shift to the very core of our
expression so we know that words are are
powerful the key to a successful
affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our
mind number one number two we must
communicate in the language that the
subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can
say
I had a friend of mine when I was
working in the corporations that had
affirmations all over his office all
over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would
carpool in you know my Perfect Mate is
manifesting for me now my Perfect Mate
is manifesting for me now that was his
affirmation and I said do you say these
things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work
for you he says Nah
you know these these things don't work
and I said why do you think they don't
work and he said look at me he says I'm
an engineer I'm a slob he said I I wear
the same clothes to work three out of
five days during the week you know and
and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even
he didn't believe that he was worthy of
his Perfect Mate manifesting for him now
so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the
underlying emotion and what he was
actually feeding into his his system was
counter to what those words were saying
so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and
cherished spiritual Traditions those
words are what become the prayers
and for many people I have and I know
you've heard this as well a lot of
people feel that prayer is broken that
the world doesn't work today the way it
worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us
and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our
relationship
fundamental physics of our relationship
to our world uh have been minced and
parceled and in many cases deleted from
the texts leaving us with a sense that
we are essentially powerless beings and
if you are powerless then you are a
victim and if you're a victim you need a
savior and that savior is coming to us
on a silver plate in terms of technology
in terms of political leaders I will
save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the
most the most powerful acts and the most
radical act we can do is to think for
ourselves uh original thinking based
upon the Deep truth of our relationship
to our bodies in the earth not based
upon the false assumptions of obsolete
science that permeate our academic world
right now it's one of the reasons I left
Academia it's one of the reasons many of
my colleagues who are in this genre who
are very well respected scientists have
left Academia because they were not
allowed to share with students and in
their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that
reflects a very different reality now
for me it's it's a uh it's good news
it's a beautiful message of Hope and
possibility uh as a sovereign biological
being
for a system that's based on centralized
power and control it's probably the
worst news they could imagine because it
means we don't need the centralized
power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our
own power because it frees us from the
fear of a changing world and we all know
our world my world is changing your
world is changing nor has it ever faster
than we can document it in our
classrooms and textbooks
but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known
in the past and this is where the fear
comes in
so the the new discoveries helping us to
understand
we are part of rather than separate from
our world and this is this is where the
affirmations come in so
in I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland
where the the physics experiments that
are revealing
what happened moments after our universe
began they recreate
the beginning of our universe and then
they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that
we are experiencing that we're living
under right now
and what they announced in 2012 is that
there is in fact a field
an intelligent field of energy it's a
subtle energy that underlies all of
creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a
lot of people felt like it was a new age
concept you know we are all one
everything is is connected or an
indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's
where they got stuck
and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and
they'll say oh yeah there's that's
that's no longer controversial there is
a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go
like this there's a field out there that
connects all things because
subconsciously they're still saying
we're separate from that field right but
here's what the science is showing us
and this this was a game changer for me
uh just a mind blower that every atom
in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not
like it's about to happen that's it's
happening right now every atom is
constantly emerging and collapsing into
that field
and what that says to us is that we are
the field it's not the fields out there
we literally are wrinkles we are
disturbances in this field this this
body
that is held in place by a conscious
awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth
I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that
means
is that if I want to bring about change
in my world I don't have to force a
change out there I become that change
and as I have become that change the
field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a
subtle but it's a very powerful way a
very different way of thinking you're
not you're not imposing change on the
world around you you are becoming the
change so you're becoming the abundance
you're becoming uh the love the
Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those
things and that is very different we're
conditioned to ask for them to plead for
them because we're led to feel powerless
in our lives when in fact there are
modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited
from the the religious texts in the
fourth Century by the church they took
they took out the information helping us
to understand that this this deep
relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a a
form of Prayer
our prayer is a form of affirmation
however you want to look at it where we
are communicating and I want to be
really clear it's not about control it's
not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about
participating
in the way that this field unfolds and
expresses in in our lives and when you
really begin to get that shift
[Music]
well and it's powerful it's not making
something happen out there and that
means you can't blame
what's out there for your experiences I
I come from a very dysfunctional broken
family and I had to make a choice early
in life
as to whether or not I would and
Community as to whether or not I would
allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence
other people around me had the same
experience and they made very different
choices they today continue to blame
their environment their parents their
family their upbringing
for the sad and unfortunate things in
their lives and and that's a path it's
not right we're on good or bad but we
have a choice to make another path and
when we begin as a scientist beginning
to understand these relationships gave
me the reason to think differently
and it also gave me the reason to test
in my life
if those thoughts are really true or not
what works and what doesn't
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn about money check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there start young the big
thing about it is we started building
this little snowball on top of a very
long hill so we started a very early age
enrolling the snowball down and of
course the snowball the nature of
Compounders versus it behaves like a
snowball